[Music]
hi and welcome to the episode 179 of the
weekly Google cloud platform podcast I
am John Fowles and I'm here with my
colleague and friend mark mission Donny
hi mark how's it going hey John I'm so
glad that you called me your friend as
well as your colleague you know what
you're my friend too John I mean we did
share a Carol right uh playing super
smash brothers during Google i/o so I'm
pretty sure we're really good friends
that was one of the most fun uber ride I
might have ever had that was a lot of
fun you know to kind of take some
downtime because that event was who I
was a lot and it was kind of nice just
to spend 30 minutes I mean admittedly we
were stuck in traffic which made our
gameplay a little bit longer so it was
pretty cool oh yeah somebody's the
better right that could have lasted for
three hours and it would have been great
so what are we talking about in this
episode sure so in this episode we'll be
talking to Rory petty product manager
for stackdriver
we're gonna talk about the new thing
stuff driver has to offer as well as
some helpful tips from a product manager
himself and we will also get into our
question a week which will help you
decide whether you should use Apps
Script or app maker when you're trying
to build out your app Oh sounds like a
good episode full of learning things and
I think our listeners were really
excited about the cool things that we
have in store for this week
we want to kick things off mark yeah
absolutely well I think the coolest
thing that I have found this week is you
know we're just coming off of cube con
in Barcelona and we know that some of
our colleagues went one of our coasts
Michele was that cube con I believe she
was speaking and one of the best things
that has come out of queue con is
everything so if you didn't get a chance
to make it
there's tons of content on YouTube so
we'll have a link down in the show notes
talking about well actually just linking
to all the different talks that happen
there there was a big you know this is
the five-year anniversary of kubernetes
so great on them and of course there's a
lot of cool content around the changes
they're making new editions and I think
that the kubernetes podcast also does a
good job of talking about and recapping
all the great happenings yeah those guys
are great I guess for me another cool
thing that I noticed is on my commute to
work yesterday I noticed that there are
new terminals for your smart device
where you can use Google pay to actually
pay your way through your turnstiles
which is kind of cool because we're you
know advancing into technology we're
pretty soon will has flying cars but you
can also use Google assistant to help
you plan your commute so you can ask
your Google assistant hey Google how
long will it take me to get to work or
what is the fastest way for me to get to
work and Google assistant will we don't
readily help you so it's pretty good to
help especially when you're going
through a large transportation hub and
you want to know which train you should
take in which the fastest way yeah you
know I hadn't considered that but when
we are in our flying cards and then we
had to stop at a toll booth I guess the
whole idea of having to throw change
into a bucket just wouldn't quite
resonate with our cars and the ability
to kind of zoom off alright and I mean
granted I did like working on my jump
shot when throwing change but I mean
let's just be serious we're advancing to
a time where pretty soon pretty soon
we'll have flying jetpacks
yeah I mean who needs the cars we'll
just go straight for teleportation let's
just go all the way oh yeah or we can do
just like Futurama and have those little
tubes and Urbanek tube system yeah that
seems so backwards for me right like is
that really futuristic cuz we've had
those tubes
since these decades ago for mayo and
something about just shoving people and
tubes I don't know if I think I'll take
the jetpacks you know it was got me
about those shows is when you go into
the tube you're upright but when you
come out of tube you're also upright so
what point in the tube do you flip
around that is a plot hole I demand an
email from the creators explaining how
this works but you know what
I get the feeling that they will have
better things to work on right and
another cool thing that our team has
been really talking about in chat was
the early preview for a are in Google
Maps it was shown up at Google i/o where
you can actually put your pixel phone in
AR mode while navigating and it will
help you with turn-by-turn directions
on-screen so there's no second guess in
the direction you're going in especially
when you can see the landmarks in Google
Maps will actually show you which
landmark you're looking at which
direction you need to turn which
direction you face and you know how far
you need to actually walk which is kind
of Awesome yeah I mean we're not at
those flying cars yet but I think
anything that improves the kind of the
driving experience especially using kind
of the it's a good showcase of how AR
can really be used in real life to say
hey look let's make our lives better
let's make things easier cool so that'll
do it for the cool things of the week so
let's get right into it with Rory and
talk about the cool things that sector
has to offer sounds good
all right thanks so much for joining us
Rory why don't you tell us a little bit
about who you are and what you do at
Google
yeah my name is Rory petty I'm a PM a
product manager on stackdriver and a lot
of people aren't familiar with the
stackdriver brand name but that's
basically the brand name that
encompasses the suite of monitoring
observability and logging tools for
Google cloud so for example within snap
driver there is a tool for monitoring
like I said logging and then also our
APM tools which are application
performance management tools so that
includes things like debugger trace
profiler so really this kind of whole
suite of tools that lets you understand
how your website or your application is
performing so I like to kind of liken it
back to the dashboard in your car if
you're driving down the highway the
dashboard tells you how fast you're
going if your engines about to overheat
are you about to run out of gas and so
in the same way the step driver suite
when you have it hooked up to your
mobile application your website your
e-commerce store whatever it provides
you kind of those critical insights into
how your service or site is performing
so what's your role within the program
manager for stackdriver what is that
kind of entail product manager maybe I
just spoke so basically I work on
product for staff driver monitoring so I
work on the core monitoring API is I
work on query notation which is a new
feature that we have in alpha right now
which I can talk about more in a little
bit I also work on our systems that
handle alerting and notifications kind
of how you are able to tell the system
hey you know alert me and notify me if
something's going wrong with my system
that's kind of my focus area gotcha so
that sounds really interesting because I
just started using staff driver myself
recently because like many of our
developers they just want to build the
solution right away but when things go
wacky or when things are uploaded they
don't really actually have the time to
follow up and actually monitor and
actually get these alerts so I recently
just started using alerts for when my
noogler project goes off whenever
anything fails so can you tell our
listeners a little bit more about the
type of alerts that you actually get
sure so there's
a variety of alerts that you can set up
with stackdriver monitoring so I'll
start out by saying that in terms of all
the Google cloud services that are out
there stackdriver supports them sector
by monitoring and logging supports them
out of the box so for example if you
spin up a new compute instance a new
compute PM or you spin up an app engine
instance all that kind of stuff they
automatically start sending metrics and
logs to stackdriver for you so you
really in most cases for a VM you might
have to install an agent or a couple
other things but you're basically
getting out-of-the-box metrics and logs
and so you know I like to think about it
in a couple stages first is I'm
receiving this kind of telemetry data
from my VM from my application just let
me look at the data and understand it
right so that could be I'm looking at
you know CPU usage or network latency it
could be something more complicated if I
have you know created SL O's from my
service but basically you know you're
getting this data you're kind of
figuring out what's the steady state of
your system and then you know what's the
state of your system where it's going to
start to degrade so for example you know
if your CPU is at a hundred percent on
the VM and you can't accept new incoming
requests or you know if you run out of
storage or any of the million different
things that could happen so that's where
alerts come into play is where you say
okay I know what the correct state of my
system should be and if certain metrics
start to go past these certain
thresholds then alert me because I
should come back and take a look at it
and I should spin up new servers or I
should figure out if a bug was deployed
whatever the case may be so with alerts
there's a couple of different approaches
the first is you can alert on metrics so
these would be GCP service metrics that
the services send again app engine GCE
gke whatever it can also be custom
metrics so for example say I have an
e-commerce store every time someone
checks out I may want to write a metric
to stackdriver to say a checkout just
happened so from that I can then you
know later I can visualize these metrics
like I could have a dashboard of the
number of checkouts per day or per hour
you know I could do other kind of
analysis or math on that to kind of
you know tell me like what's the amount
of time that it takes between checkouts
or how frequently are my high-value
customers checking out all that kind of
stuff another approach that you can take
if you've read the Google SR e-book draw
to this distinction between white box
monitoring and black box monitoring so
white box monitoring is when your
service or system emits metrics right
like your VM is constantly sending CPU
usage metrics Network metrics whatever
but a black box is literally just that
it's it'd be basically say I don't know
the contents of this system but I'm
going to ping it and say hey are you
alive are you working so basically in
stackdriver you can go in and create
what's called an uptime check and
Google's you know HTTP prober service
that we run globally it's also the same
service that Google uses to black box
monitor its own internal tools and
services it can basically send an HTTP
request to a URL endpoint for your app
and not only say hey are you up but it
can actually check the contents of the
response so I'm gonna hit the you know
shopping cart URL endpoint of my
e-commerce service and I'm gonna check
the response to say okay you know am I
getting certain HTML form fields back am
I getting certain values so you can kind
of do basically like a next order set of
checks to make sure that your service is
healthy and so again going back to the
SRA book you know it kind of has this
recommendation that for a Vance
monitoring practice you should really
use both you should have alerts set up
on the white box metrics that are being
exported by your service and then you
should also have kind of these black box
probers that are probing the health and
liveliness of your service as well
sounds awesome one thing that you said
that I think our listeners will be
interested in hearing about is you use
the word monitoring quite a bit and I'm
pretty sure that stackdriver has some
type of monitoring UI or some visuals
that we can actually help you know trace
our logs and everything so can you talk
more about that basically in Google
Cloud console you know if you go kind of
to that left nav that slides out and has
a million options
there's a stack driver section and again
that is broken out into the core staff
driver services of monitoring logging
and then the other APM tools trace
our debugger so monitoring specifically
when you go into monitoring it'll first
ask you to create a workspace and the
reason that we have this workspace
construct is that oftentimes people want
to monitor one or more projects of
theirs in Google Cloud so for example
you can imagine a scenario where I work
at a company and I'm assistant min or
I'm an SRE or developer or whatever the
case is and we have our website could be
ecommerce provider like you know
target.com or something like that but
it's probably at a certain scale divided
across multiple projects so you might
have a front-end for the website that's
being driven by services out of one
project you might have a you know
shopping cart or payment gateways
service that runs on another project so
long story short you want to monitor all
of these kind of in the same place and
so a workspace you can put multiple
projects into a workspace that can give
you visibility across all of them at the
same time so you know John going back to
your question once you go into the staff
driver a monitoring section there's a
variety of things you can do one is that
there's this section called resources
where we actually create out-of-the-box
dashboards for you for a variety of
common resources so that could be cloud
storage VM instances App Engine Google
kubernetes engine and all of those so
you actually don't have to do a lot of
configuration out of the box for example
say let's select one of our GCE VM
instances we're gonna give you CPU usage
memory usage uptime cheque latency gonna
show you events related to that
particular VM whether you have uptime
cheques configured what's the network
traffic look like so you know a lot of
people are worried about oh is it
complicated to set up and start using
stackdriver again like for a variety of
use cases it's pretty simple and kind of
just works out of the box now if you
have more complicated needs you know
more advanced needs you want to set up
your own dashboards that is certainly a
functionality that we support so you can
go in create a custom dashboard and say
you know oh I want I want to create a
dashboard that tracks the health of my
shopping cart service for my e-commerce
website so you can do a variety of
charts and graphs that again measure any
metric that that server
six ports so that again could be CPU
disk memory network custom metrics that
you're writing it's really configurable
however you want stack driver also just
recently launched a new product called
service monitoring that basically went
into alpha at Google cloud next in San
Francisco back in April so the idea
behind that is that let's say you're
running like a gke cluster there is an
open-source project called sto which is
basically software that helps you define
basically a mesh for your micro services
so it's everything from like the control
plane to metrics to how the services
talk to each other authenticate is theö
handles all of that and so the cool
thing is that this teo borrows a lot of
architecture from how Google manages its
services from micro services internally
and so sto once you configure it
out-of-the-box will give you metrics and
traces and a variety of other telemetry
that you can use to better understand
your system and so service monitoring
not only makes it easy to configure all
of that you can actually see it visually
in this kind of topology graph so you
can imagine like in Google Maps a visual
map of you know these are where
different points of interest or
locations are on the map step driver
service monitoring will actually show
you a visual map of your entire micro
service architecture it'll show you
where all the VMS are who's talking to
what how much traffic and like how many
queries per second are going between
various instances and endpoints it's
pretty cool we're hoping to get to you a
public beta of it later in the year we
don't have a definitive timeline yet but
I think it's something that a lot of
people will be very excited to work with
so I mean that's a that's a pretty deep
dive on a lot of the monitoring side of
things of stackdriver but there's a lot
more to it you know you mentioned
logging a little bit earlier but you
also kind of mentioned a collection of
other tools you know in your talking
about the SRA book would you say that
you know maybe stack driver is a little
bit more designed as a set of tools to
kind of support this SRA cycle so it's
interesting you know there's no one true
way to like kind of monitor and maintain
your systems right obviously you know
Google has like a very specific point of
view with the SRA book but the point of
the stack driver suite of tools which
again to your point is not just
monitoring
is logging and a variety of other tools
is to really meet customers where
they're at we have baked some of the
best SRA principles into the stackdriver
tools but if that's not part of your
DevOps practice then we want the tools
to still be useful to you so for example
there are still a lot of companies or
development organizations that the
primary way that they understand and
debug their systems is through logs
right so you know they'll log all these
different important touch points within
their code if there are errors they'll
dump stack traces they'll dump a variety
of other information and so their
developers are both watching logs in
real time and they're also creating
alerts on their logs that's actually
another interesting point that you
brought up mark which is that
stackdriver is a set of different tools
but there are a lot of like horizontal
journeys and capabilities that tie all
the tools together so for example let's
say that I'm logging my java application
to you snap driver logging and let's say
that you know every time someone checks
out
in my e-commerce shop I write a log
entry or every time that someone you
know encounters a problem I write a log
entry that's an error an exception or
that kind of thing you can actually
create what's called a logs based metric
in logging which basically says every
time this kind of log entry happens I
mean you can do simple matching against
the log entry you can match on like a
regex and say like if the log entry
contains these kind of words or phrases
or matches against this regex
basically you know write a data point as
part of a time series and then that time
series that is created from the log
again this log based metric you can do
all kinds of things with you can
visualize it on the dashboard you can
create an alert off of it so while the
products are separate they are kind of
intimately tied together in terms of how
you would use them as part of a DevOps
practice so somebody could come in and
you know maybe just say alright I have
everything kind of figured out on my
side but I want some nice dashboard for
monitoring stackdriver could kind of
offer that through the monitoring
service and the the dashboards that are
built in or the ones that you can
customize but if you're kind of starting
from scratch maybe you can adopt a lot
of the different stack driver tools and
have that almost Google centric sre idea
right
yeah very much so like we want the tools
to meet your needs so if you just want
to use monitoring or logging that's fine
but you really get the most value out of
the suite the more tools that you use so
for example you might start by just
configuring monitoring and logging but
then you'll see a lot of added value if
you add in trace or debugger or profiler
again at the end of the day it all goes
back to you how can we help you debug
issues that you're having in your system
and how can we help you understand your
system so logging and monitoring are
very much kind of like the bedrock of
that practice but you know as an
industry and it's not just Google like
there are a variety of other cloud
providers and in other kind of service
providers in the market that provide APM
tools trace profiler that kind of stuff
so what we're realizing as an industry
is that logging and monitoring are great
for a lot of things they're not always
the best tool to debug really
complicated issues and so that's where
again some of these second-order tools
like the APM tools come into play so
we've actually talked about just
shocking amount in a short period of
time right way more than from the days I
remember of just kind of like you said
var dumping out a bunch of stuff and
checking for what I wanted to grab
there's been a lot of people looking to
kind of adopt stackdriver
obviously it has a lot of power behind
it and I think one of the more recent
tools that has come out to help that is
the stack driver sandbox can you talk a
little bit more about what that is what
its aim is and how people can use it
yeah stack driver sandbox is a cool
project that has just come out of Google
recently where one of the things that we
find is that people want to better
understand how monitoring and logging
and apium tools like stack driver work
but they're kind of afraid to set them
up on their production environment right
like they don't want to cause any
disruption and they kind of want to just
kick the tires in a safe way you know
learn how the products work learn them a
little bit better and then figure out
kind of what's there on ramp to
implementing them as part of their
DevOps practice and so basically the SAP
driver sandbox gives you a really easy
way with like essentially one script
that you just run and it will configure
an entire kind of sandbox or test stack
driver environment for you
where you can kind of you know
spin up any kind of test vm's that you
want spin up any kubernetes clusters you
know you could create effectively like a
whole mirror of your staging or
production systems there but in a safe
environment that once you're done with
it you can tear down and you know you
don't have to worry about you
accidentally left something running and
you're incurring billing and all of that
so it's it's a very cost effective and
safe way to kind of better understand
the whole suite of tools that
stackdriver provides that's awesome so
I'm wearing you you mentioned that this
is relatively new and you mentioned a
couple of times that a couple of the
products are going at alpha and beta can
you tell us a little bit more about what
the roadmap 4-step drivers looking like
sure yeah so one thing I would say is I
would go check out a lot of the
announcements that we just made in April
at Google cloud next in San Francisco
like all of the staff driver talks are
available on YouTube I think one of the
conference websites is like cloud on air
google.com or I mean basically if you
just Google for like GCP next and cloud
on air there's a huge list of the
various talks that cover stackdriver and
DevOps and all of that but a couple
things that we announced one is that our
profiler tool went GA so we haven't
talked about profiler a lot yet but it's
also a really cool tool to understand
the performance of your system so
basically what it does is you basically
include a library in your software and
do some basic configuration and what it
will do is as your services running it
will periodically pull your CPU usage
pull your memory usage and then
basically it profiles your call stack of
your running application and it will
tell you percentage-wise where you spend
the most time so for example you could
imagine you have a web server that you
know is receiving requests and adding an
item to a shopping cart and so in the
profiler you might go in and say okay
why is this one URL endpoint this this
API handler for the shopping cart why is
it taking so long because it's taking
like five seconds on average to add an
item to the shopping cart so you go in
and profiler and you look at it and you
can clearly see oh this one function or
this one method say for example like a
JSON D serialization method or something
like that this is actually taking up 90%
of the time
my total response time so as a developer
you're able to say oh like I need to go
in and optimize this function you know I
need to improve my code a variety of
things right so it's basically a tool
for developers that really lets them
optimize their code and what we've seen
in practice is when big companies use it
not only are they able to improve the
performance of their code but that
translates back into not just benefits
for their users but actually benefits
for their cloud spend so again the less
time you're spinning CPU cycles you know
you might be able to save money on your
compute cost or the amount of memory
that you need for a particular VM
instance so it can be one of those cases
where a little bit of time investment
there can actually save you you know a
large amount of money or user
satisfaction in terms of like real-world
benefit yeah I think that for the cloud
on air that you were mentioning if
people can go to the Google cloud
platform YouTube channel if you search
stackdriver there you'll actually see a
fair amount of content we've got this
series called stack doctor where we talk
about some of the best practices and
getting started with stack driver as
well as a bunch of kind of like webinars
with cloud on air where we'll talk about
different areas I think there was a
recent one on the profiler for instance
and kind of how those things work and
kind of stepping into it I think there's
a lot of resources out there for
hopefully people to learn more about
Strack driver because a lot of cases
it's not just gonna be a plug-and-play
right you're gonna have to do a fair
amount of work integrating it but the
more you integrate it and kind of the
more you lean into it like you just said
the more rewards you'll see yeah and I
think part of the value of stackdriver
too is that it provides a lot of these
tools and services across the whole
spectrum of DevOps needs so for example
one thing that we see a lot of times
talking to customers that are new to GCP
you know they might have one tool or
service provider that just does logging
or another tool that does monitoring
another tool that does trace or profiler
or that kind of thing and obviously we
want customers to use the right tools
based on what their needs are but there
is a value in using a single suite of
tools that are all designed to work
together and can kind of you know get
you closer to that single pane of glass
that is so often talked about in the
DevOps community of you know what's a
single place that I can go and I can see
all the telemetry you know and I can
basically have like a God's eye view of
my system
can see my logs my metrics my traces all
the telemetry all together with that
being said what would you kind of say
your favorite piece of stackdriver is
that's tough I mean I'm a little biased
because I work on the monitoring tool so
I think that there's a lot of value that
monitoring provides you know I also
think that there's a lot of value in our
APM tools so trace is particularly
interesting because again if you have
like kind of a service-based
architecture you can imagine a scenario
again we use the shopping cart scenario
where customer clicks Add to Cart but
behind the scenes there might actually
be tens of different services that talk
to each other so you know the web server
has to call the currency conversion
service to convert from dollars to euros
and then it has to call the warehouse
inventory system like is this item still
in stock you know you could imagine just
one simple web request having to cascade
into all these different internal
service calls and so that's where using
traditional tools like logging and
debugging it can be really difficult to
figure out what's gone wrong or where
the performance problem is because you
know you might be looking at hundreds of
log entries across tens of different
services so what trace does is it gives
you this kind of waterfall view that
shows you all of the internal service
requests stitched together so you can
very quickly and easily visually see
what's taking the most time in all of
these service requests which in turn
over request has the most latency and is
affecting the performance of my system
so I think trace is a really cool tool
in that regard also a tool that doesn't
get as much love but I think is super
powerful is debugger and so you know so
many people are familiar with debuggers
in the context of you know developing
your application right so you're writing
code you're testing it it's not quite
working right so you put a breakpoint in
your code and then you you know click a
button in your website app whatever and
then basically when it reaches that
point in your code execution will pause
and you can see basically all of the
context of what's going on in your call
stack at that point so you can see what
are the value of different variables you
can see a whole variety of things so
again like this is a very common you
know workflow for a developer what's
hard is
when you're running an application in
production you can't effectively pause
the code right like if a customer is
having an issue
I can't pause the code which pauses
execution for that customer or all the
customers but what's kind of cool and
magical is that if you configure your
website or application to work with snap
driver debugger it will effectively take
snapshots of the internal state of your
application such that you can actually
link your code so if your code is in
like github or you know google source
repositories or whatever you can
actually set breakpoints in your code
and you can view at that breakpoint
the contexts of live production traffic
with a zero performance hit to your
actual running web application so it's
pretty magical like it basically lets
you debug production code on the fly
with no performance hit also another
capability that it has is you can
basically use it to insert log lines
into production code so I mean as
developers how many times does this
happen right where you have an
application you roll out some new code
and there's a bug or it's not performing
like it should so you say okay how can I
figure out what's going wrong so you go
back to your code you add a bunch more
log lines you add a bunch more logging
now you have to redeploy your entire
application just to see in your logs you
know the state of things what's
happening what's gone wrong and so where
that becomes really tricky is that
you've now made it 10 times harder to
isolate the actual issue because when
you redeploy your code there's a huge
other variety of variables that could
change things that could go wrong that
kind of thing so basically without doing
a new code deploy debugger allows you to
insert log lines in to live running code
to better understand and diagnose and
debug a problem so I hope I did it
justice through that explanation it's a
really cool tool and frankly there are
not very many other tools like that on
the market that can do you know live
production debugging with basically zero
performance impact yeah I mean I think
that's a dream for a lot of people but
if I understood you correctly your
favorite part about stackdriver is
basically all of stackdriver
yeah I feel like I kind of dodged your
question and you know talked about
everything well it's it's cool there's a
lot of good stuff in there right yeah
yes it's it's hard it's hard to pick
favorites and again I think it goes back
to you what I think is a common
misunderstanding that like you should
really think of stackdriver as separate
products I mean there is again logging
and monitoring and all of that but they
really are meant to work together as a
suite of tools so you know don't think
of like logging as a hammer and
monitoring as a saw think of it as you
know these are all the tools in a
toolbox that I'm using to repair my
house build a house like whatever your
hockey analogy is there but they really
are a suite of tools meant to work
together
your explanation was spot-on for me
because I've actually used it annex a
exact scenario where I needed to test
something and I was working with the
teammates so we were able to not only
throw in log lines in the middle of our
code without having to actually you know
change anything and using the debugger
we found like several edge cases that we
definitely missed and we have like an
internal project that I worked on that
it's currently in production and can be
used internally by Googlers and it was
pretty awesome using structure before
the first time because I wouldn't have
actually found those edge cases in that
scenario I'm actually kind of curious if
there are any really impressive use
cases that you've heard any of our
customers using or any developers that
you've met I'm not sure if you can touch
on that a little bit again some of these
are on the GCP youtube channel but this
year next we had quite a few sessions
that we're kind of co-led with customers
so Samsung did a session on how they use
stackdriver to monitor the performance
of a lot of their systems you know
obviously Samsung is a huge electronics
conglomerate so they have a huge variety
of web-based services that they have to
run and maintain so they talked about
how they use stackdriver to calculate a
solos for their services back hair
budgets things like that so yeah there
were quite a few different companies
kind of at that scale dinner using
stackdriver and have done public talks
so I would highly recommend checking out
the YouTube channel there were a lot of
good talks where you know it's not just
the stackdriver team giving you a sales
pitch or telling you you stackdriver
it's I think a lot more powerful when
you hear like these are customers that
are having success with the product that
are able to use it to meet their needs a
very large scale I think that's where
the rubber meets the road and you know
you can kind of see the real value of
the product awesome
so we're running a little short on time
but I just wanted to give you the
opportunity so speak on anything that we
might have missed or anything you want
to mention before you know wrap things
up yeah I would just say that you know
while there are a lot of products in the
stock driver suite you know I think it's
not something to be afraid of I mean
whether you're using the sandbox or
whether you're just creating a test
environment it's really easy just to
start using stackdriver and to kick the
tires on it and like I mentioned if you
go to the stack driver documentation if
you search for kind of the list of
metrics you can see across all the
different GCP services pretty much all
of them are already integrated out of
the box with step driver so you know our
goal is to be the best set of you know
DevOps tools for Google Cloud so it's
really easy to start using stack driver
and to get value out of the box without
configuring anything I will also say
that while our primary focus is on
Google Cloud we do support other clouds
we are a multi cloud service so we do
our logging and monitoring metrics of
support AWS so if you're you know if you
still primarily are on AWS or maybe you
have a hybrid multi cloud architecture
we definitely support that functionality
we also have a new feature we've rolled
out with a partner called blue Medora
where they have another agent that you
can install that not only supports other
clouds like asher it supports a wide
variety of use cases could be the
windows vm's a huge number like hundreds
of different open-source products and
services so a central point is that
whatever kind of infrastructure you're
running whether it's you know on Prem in
the cloud some kind of hybrid thereof
Windows Linux monolithic apps
microservices stack driver will support
your use case and help give you
observability into your systems very
cool well thanks so much for joining us
Rory and telling us a lot about I think
a whole bunch about the different tools
that are inside a stack driver and then
I think that you know for people who are
interested hopefully there's a lot of
tools out there for them to kind of get
learning pretty quickly yeah I would say
you know check out the stack driver
YouTube channel along with the GCP
channel there
a lot of great content on there one of
our DevOps engineers Yuri has a YouTube
channel or show called stack doctor
so that's sta CK doctor and he digs into
a lot of the finer points of stackdriver
will show you how to configure various
things how to do kind of advanced use
cases it's really good content then also
you know feel free to follow our blog we
have new product announcements there we
post a lot of best practices they're
really getting into a lot of the details
about how to best configure your alert
policies how to best configure your
logging setup so there's a lot of
content out there for people that are
interested in how to structure their
DevOps practice from google cloud and
beyond awesome mark and I would like to
thank Rory for joining us and Rory once
again it's been a pleasure yeah thanks
guys thanks for having me well thanks
again for helping our listeners
understand the cool things that you
could do with stackdriver
and the new features and new
announcement that has recently just come
out yeah you know there's always a lot
of things on the roadmap and stackdriver
is such a broad set of different tools
like we talked about I think that you
know you can definitely find something
in there that you can integrate with
your app to hopefully increase the
observability or just make life a little
easier right and I know that it's made
my life quite a bit easier especially
when I've actually deployed my
application and I really need to debug
it but you know on the local level I
just don't really want to do it I'd much
rather do it well my app is running in
club so let's get into our question of
the week
I think you've seen a blog post that
probably sparked this but I guess our
question is how do you decide between
app script and app maker when you
actually want to build out your
application absolutely and just like you
mentioned there is a blog post that kind
of dives into the details about why you
might choose one over the other
they're both great tools to create and
customize the experience for users on
the G suite side of things but there's a
couple of key differences and when
you're trying to decide between them the
important things to keep in mind are you
know how much you want to rely on the G
suite experience or do you want to build
a custom user interface are you just
kind of adding additional functionality
which is something that's Apps Script is
great for right it's based on JavaScript
you're able to go in and kind of say
okay well users using this sheet let me
add some custom JavaScript functionality
so that when they do this I can automate
this task for them or are you looking to
build kind of a self-contained
experience where you have full access
you can hook it up to cloud sequel so
you can actually back it with a full
database and then kind of create this
curated content for them that's much
more of what that Maker should be so you
kind of have that choice between the two
of them again the blog post kind of asks
a couple of questions and tells you why
you might consider one over the other
but either way ultimately people
especially we at Google but I think a
lot of businesses spend a lot of time in
G suite whether it's Docs or sheets or
whatever there's so much going on in
there anything you can do around
automating or making tasks easy in there
or adding additional functionality both
of them are great ways to do that and
really just save time or really kind of
add surprising features awesome I
probably now look at this blog post
because I definitely do a lot of
application design and creation around
the cool gaming things that I work on
and it'd be kind of cool to see the
difference between app maker and Apps
Script personally but also it'll help me
make the decision on which I should
probably use for my application just to
improve that production process I mean
absolutely I do a tremendous amount of
spreadsheet work and you know every time
I put something into a spreadsheet if I
have to do it more than like five or six
times you know I have to ask myself is
this something easier that I can
actually just build a script floor which
is always going to be a trade-off
depending on exactly you know how much
time do you want to invest in making a
reusable
by every spreadsheet and some Doc's that
I'd work on it's just like I want a
script to help me with this awesome so
mark what will you be doing pretty soon
like what are you getting into any
trouble you got planned you know I'm not
a big traveler but I will be going to
New York hopefully we can maybe sit down
and play some Smash Brothers while I'm
out there
think you'll be in town right so for me
I'll be in town and I'll be attending
games for change which is going to be
awesome this is my first games for
change and I'm real excited to go for
those of you that do not know games for
change is essentially a conference that
brings game developers who are using
games as a platform to empower social
impact and educate those in the actual
power of behind games because a lot of
people don't really know how much
influence games have and it's great for
kids because games are a really big
pivotal part of your childhood for most
children in some way some fashion and it
doesn't actually have to be video games
but games in general is a very big
platform because it brings up a lot of
social issues it can help educate people
on biases so it'd be great to actually
see how a lot of developers are actually
using these games to make a conscious
effort to make things better yeah it's
really cool to see all of the smaller
indie game studios or even just
individual people who are creating games
to kind of show not only some of the
social issues that exist but also to
help enable people to kind of create
their own games or I think we've seen a
couple of games that try to take machine
learning and explain that in a in a much
more approachable way and I think
there's a wide variety whether it's
teaching people about you know stem
technologies or whether it's more on the
kind of social and cultural issue sides
I think that games are just a different
kind of medium for people to actually
approach the education world with yeah
so I think it's like the 15th or 16th
summit they've had so you know I'm sure
there's a lot of cool things that have
changed over the past decade so it's
really great to see a lot of people kind
of come into the same place and talk
about all the things that they're
working on and all the ways to enable
people and I'm glad that I'm currently
working games and also trying to make a
conscious effort to help developers and
users all over the world
well that'll wrap things up for
us on this episode of the Google cloud
platform podcast thank you for listening
and we'll all see you next week thanks
mark
thanks John we'll see you next time
[Music]
we don't have to do this that's what
that great editors are for you guys are
awesome